the national constitution center in
philadelphia the birthplace of america
is now home to another historic first
last night hillary clinton became the
first woman ever chosen by a major party
to be their presidential nominee
democratic convention delegates ratified
the historic nomination many Bernie
Sanders supporters greeted the outcome
by leaving the convention President
Obama will speak tonight and supported
Hillary Clinton so we'll Vice President
Joe Biden and Clinton's running mate
senator Tim Kaine last night former
President Bill Clinton told a very
personal story of the nominee as a wife
a mom and a leader Nancy Cordes is high
above the convention floor at Wells
Fargo Center Nancy good morning good
morning you know there are a lot of
politicians on this stage this week who
are vouching for Hillary Clinton the
candidate but President Clinton seemed
more focused on painting a picture of
the kind of woman she is a woman whose
image he argued has been distorted by
decades of GOP attacks I'm married my
best friend the former president told
the story of their courtship Parenthood
and the strengths his wife brought to
their marriage well she's insatiably
curious she's a natural leader she's a
good organizer and she's the best darn
changemaker I ever met in my entire life
he said Republicans were trying to turn
his wife into a cartoon villain one is
real the other is made up good for you
because earlier today you nominated the
real 27 votes for the first woman
president earlier in the night delegates
cast their ballots state by state or
again feeling the burn
he bounced for senator
Vermont super delegate Bernie Sanders
announced that Clinton had gone over the
top I move that Hillary Clinton be
selected as the nominee of the
Democratic Party it was a gesture of
unity but several hundred Sanders
supporters walked out anyway this is not
democracy and this is what Bernie was
trying to fix inside the program
continue it's time to stand together and
be unified you people have made history
images of the nation's first 44
presidents all of them male were
projected above the stage a glass
ceiling shattered revealing Hillary
Clinton in a surprise satellite
appearance I may become the first woman
president but one of you is next Thank
historic moment with Jamie and Smith to
tears it just shows that hard work
actually pays off you know it's like
it's not just about how much I would you
look like or you know what kind of man
you have on your arm you actually can do
things and actually be recognized for it
she and many others were quick to
acknowledge that the real glass ceiling
is the presidency itself and that
they've got a lot of work to do to help
Hillary Clinton shatter it come November
Nora all right Nancy thank you so much